die nibelungen ein deutscher stumpfem
heißt das neue buch von felicitas hoppe
in dieser sonderfolge des bücher
podcasts stellt die autorin ist am
buchmesse stand der faz vor im gespräch
mit tilman spreckelsen
ja herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren schön dass sie dass der raum
geradezu ausverkauf das ausgebuchte auf
jeden fall
und sogar noch weitere da sind
vielleicht kennen sie das aus eigener
erfahrung sie lesen ein buch und
plötzlich merken sie dass sie die hoch
musikalische sprache dieses buchs beim
lesen gerade zu hören können dass ein
besonderer tun sie in bann schlägt und
akustisch beide lektüre begleitet mir
begegnet das phänomen nicht oft aber
zuverlässig wenn ich ein buch von
felicitas hoppe aufschlage ob das die
reisegeschichte paradiso übersee ist der
roman johanna um die jungfrau von
orléans und ihre modernen interpreten
oder die fabelhaft erfundene biografie
hoppe zwischen eishockey ambitionen und
dirigenten rom
[Musik]
felix hoppe ist eine der am meisten mit
literaturpreisen versehen den deutschen
autoren darunter ein schlichtes des
büchner preises alle namhaften preise
unterhalb noch des nobelpreises und weil
sie weiß dass es nichts umsonst gibt
noch nicht einmal einen preis zahlt sie
zurück mit geschliffenen
funkensprühenden dankesreden von denen
einige glücklicherweise publiziert
vorliegen
sie ist eine große reisende oder wie im
fall des weltumseglers peter vetter oder
der russischen amerika fahrer 11 und
petrow auch eine große nach reisende und
sie ist eine begnadete übersetzerin etwa
der werke des amerikaners dr
heute ist sie hier mit einem neuen buch
das ich mit dem nibelungenstoff
auseinander herzlich willkommen felix
hoppe ja danke tilman spreckelsen und
schön dass sie da sind
sie haben sich das nibelungenlied
angenommen dem wird ja nachgesagt
ähnlich wie den grimmschen märchen eine
ungeheure grausamkeit ständig rollen
abgeschlagene köpfe wie geht man mit
einer solchen vorlage eines abgestimmten
vorlage oben naja also gemessen an dem
was wir so um die ohren gehauen bekommen
heutzutage an grausamkeiten vom film und
von der sogenannten wirklichkeit ist das
in den nibelungen
ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt ein
kinderspiel aber sie sind natürlich auch
in dieser stilisierten form von einer
ungeheuren gewalt und ich glaube damit
kann man nur umgehen indem man sich mit
dieser gewalt konfrontiert und versucht
zu begreifen wie sie entsteht und wie
sie generiert wird und das muss man
natürlich auch erkennen und
unterscheiden dass es hier um eine
erzählte gewalt geht die nach ganz
bestimmten formalen muss dann erzählt
wird und dadurch eine spezifische
wirkung erzielt also was ganz
automatisiert es im großen und ganzen
aber ziemlich schnittig und im vergleich
zu unseren spielfilm fast sparsam
sparsam mit der gewalt wie entsteht die
dann strukturell sie haben eben gesagt
das ist auch eine folge der erzählweise
ja in diesem fall also ich spreche ich
jetzt vom nibelungenlied entstanden um
1200 das ja in dem sind auch kein
original ist sondern auf alte stoffe
zurück geht und wenn man das genauer
studiert wie die gewalt aufgebaut ist
dann haben wir hier so eine art spirale
sierung also es ist in form einer
kettenreaktion
und was die sache so bündig macht und so
unmöglich zu knacken oder es
aufzubrechen ist dass sie nicht
reflektiert wird sondern dass sie
geschieht sie vollzieht sich und sie
muss sich vollziehen sie ist nicht
aufzuhalten es wird nicht diskutiert es
wird nicht verhandelt es gibt keine
inneren monologe es gibt angedeutet
momente des konflikts oder des zweifels
aber im grunde genommen läuft das wie
eine maschine das ganze nibelungenlied
ist eine erzähl maschine und in dieser
maschine ist das personal teil der
maschinerie und hat eigentlich gar kein
anrecht auf individualität und das finde
ich fasziniert man hat ja auch nie den
eindruck dass sich irgendjemand
irgendetwas bereit etwa schlageter
meinem schwager den kopf ab und geht
dann weiter irgendwie nein es ist
zwingend aber es ist so zwingend wie im
comic oder im stummfilm und das muss man
auch ganz klar sagen mit unseren
parametern die wir so lieben an denen
wir so hängen von gut und böse kampagne
nicht zurecht es gibt in den nibelungen
eigentlich weder gut noch böse man denkt
das so und ist geneigt in unserem zwang
der aktualisierung aber eigentlich ist
es nicht so jeder ist in seinem kosmos
vollkommen stimmig ob das der üble hagen
ist oder die dauer wird für creme die
zur rächerin wird die funktionieren in
ihrem kokon und sobald sie miteinander
schnittmengen bilden sollen haut es
nicht mehr hin beziehungsweise dann haut
es hin dann fallen die köpfe weil sie
nicht miteinander verhandeln
sie haben eben zwei stichworte gebracht
die eigentlich fast ein eines fall
nämlich einmal die maschinerie und dann
den stummfilm und da hört man eigentlich
fast an den projektor rattern das ist ja
der untertitel oder ich weiß gar nicht
ob man sagen kann die
gattungsbezeichnung
die nibelungen ein deutscher stumpfe wie
kommen sie darauf wieso das wird in der
regel natürlich für kenner der materie
als hommage an den stümpfen von fritz
lang
ausgelegt den ich in der tat sehr sehens
und bemerkenswert finde aber es ist
eigentlich keine gattungsbezeichnung
sondern das was man ja unter büchern
nicht setzen darf eigentlich wird die
methode angezeigt wenn ich sage es ist
ein stummfilm dann meine ich das
verfahren im stummfilm spielt die
sprache keine rolle es sind die bilder
es sind die bilder es sind die gesten es
sind die requisiten da sind wir fast
wieder beim märchen es ist
über formung eine verzerrung eine
groteske und wir erleben das geschehen
gestik und das ist das was wir am
passendsten erscheint in den nibelungen
das heißt jetzt nicht dass in hobbys
nibelungen nicht gesprochen wird
stellenweise wird da gesprochen aber der
charakter lebt über das bild und das war
beim schreiben die größte
herausforderung starke bilder zu finden
und die figuren in ihrem recht zu
belassen und sie trotzdem neu zu
präsentieren und der stummfilm ist das
möchte ich auch noch erwähnen also ich
weiß nicht ob ihr stumpf filmliebhaber
unter ihnen sind wir als kinder liebten
männer ohne nerven das kam immer
freitags ich glaube um 18 uhr und von
männer ohne nerven habe ich auch die u4
geklaut die ich den verlag tatsächlich
aufschwatzen konnte da steht schlicht
und einfach drama liebe wahnsinn und so
wurden diese kurzen stummfilme
angekündigt bevor jemandem die torte ins
gesicht flug und es war es gibt nichts
graus anderes als stummfilme die leute
dreschen aufeinander ein sie sägen sich
gegenseitig die bäume kaputt sie
zerschlagen ihre autos es ist eine
eskalation der gewalt und wir lieben es
vermutlich weil wir das alles gerne
selber täten und gott sei dank den film
als ventil
es gibt ja 1 1
ein netter um marsch weiterhin an den
stumpfen das im text immer wieder tafeln
eingeblendet werden die wie die tafeln
im stumpfen eben
war das mühsam den verlag davon zu
überzeugen
es ging also ich habe mich ins zeug
gelegt ursprünglich hatte ich sogar die
vorstellung sie kennen das ist ja eine
große große kunst und thea von harbou
heisse szene die die frau von fritz lang
die das drehbuch für den stummfilm
schrieb hat finde ich die genial stan
stummfilm tafeln gemacht auf stummfilm
tafel muss man sich kurz fassen und
signale geben und ursprünglich war meine
idee zwischen jedem kapitel eine
ganzseitige tafel zu haben da hat der
gestalter widersprochen das buch werde
nämlich fast doppelt so lang geworden
und das wäre da ein bisschen fake
gewesen
aber die idee hat überzeugt ich glaube
es einen praktischen grund weil die
stumpfen tafeln beim lesen auch pause
und atem verschaffen und man sehr schöne
kurze lese bilder hat das strukturiert
das lesen außerdem sieht es super aus
danke an den s fischer verlag
das nibelungenlied steht ja in dem
moment wo wir uns heute so gar nicht
mehr so mehr zum beginn des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts darüber
beugen steht ja einer sehr langen
traditionen und was weiß von von wagner
bis warum es mindestens als
eckpunkte vielleicht
wie kam es zu der entscheidung diese
tradition eigentlich mit zu denken denn
genau das passiert ja
es ist ja völlig unmöglich dass ohne die
tradition zu denken auch ohne die
jüngste dann ja die verwurstung hätte
ich fast gesagt durch den
nationalsozialismus bis hin zur görings
rede anlässlich der situation im kessel
zu stalingrad das ist
aber auch eine provokation also der
stoff so wie ich ihn dann als lead
gelesen habe den text von 1200 ihn quasi
unter diesen schichten hervorzuholen
wohl wissend dass die schichten
natürlich jede dieser schichten
hinterlässt ihre spuren an dem stoff und
das wäre ja naiv zu sagen ich gehe jetzt
zum ursprung ursprünge gibt es in der
literatur eigentlich nie und was mich
fasziniert ist als schriftstellerin
nicht originell sein zu wollen sondern
zu wissen jeder stoff ist eine leihgabe
und dieses stehen auf den schultern von
von von riesen das ist toll außerdem
wenn alle über diesen stoff schreiben
dann muss ich natürlich auch weil das
ein beweis der qualität des stoffes ist
sonst würde er nicht andauernd neu
aufgelegt werden das land zutiefst
mittelalterlicher gedanke ist jetzt
keine neuen stoff sich ran zu nehmen
sondern einen alten stoff neu zu fassen
im grunde genommen ich würde gerne sie
bitten das ist einmal hören wie das
geschieht ob sie eine kurze passage
folien könnten das mache ich mache ich
sehr gerne und wasser schmecken sind
sagt das glaube ich essentiell wichtig
gerade in einer zeit wo alles so nach
originalität gieren und natürlich in
wirklichkeit alle voneinander abkupfern
was ich toll finde und der klassische
kommentar der mittelalterlichen den
dichter ist ja immer
viele haben es vor mir erzählt aber so
gut wie ich erzählt es euch keiner dass
nämlich für mich natürlich auch in
anspruch
ich lese ein ganz kleines stück wir
befinden uns hier auf der bonner wormser
festspielbühne und es betritt jetzt
diese bühne hagen von tronje
und heute abend sie tagen besonders
schön aus nicht dass er sich etwas
verändert hätte er ist ganz der alte
denn er hat gar kein alter nur sein haar
wird jedes jahr dünner und seine stirn
etwas höher übrigens eine schöne stirn
die hohe stirn eines alterslosen
bestatters mit sehr viel erfahrung der
seine lehrjahre irgendwo im europäischen
ausland verbracht hat eine stirn hinter
der nicht gegrübelt wird weil hagen sich
auskennt und was zu tun ist wenn alle
anderen noch mit klagen beschäftigt sind
weshalb diese stirn fast zuversicht
ausstrahlt einen unaufdringlichen glanz
in dem sich das publikum gerne spiegelt
weil der widersacher ihm seit jahren
treu bleibt die verlässlichste figur in
der ganzen geschichte ein mann wie ein
pfosten nicht zu ermüden nicht zu
betrügen lässt sich nicht täuschen zu
nichts überreden ist nicht zu bestechen
unmöglich zu rühren die nur sich selbst
und jener kraft die ihm erlaubt
jederzeit ohne schlaf auszukommen
der hat keinen schlaf keine träume hat
nichts zu besprechen nichts zu bereden
schmiede tag und nacht pläne und
schreitet zur tat kein zweifel das
publikum liebt ihn denn nicht der tödter
des drachens nicht der bärenjäger und
zwergen heute nicht der besitzer des
größten schatzes der welt den niemals
jemals zugeben jemand zu heben imstande
sein wird sondern sein mörder der schatz
vernichter ist sein heimlicher held der
jetzt so lässig nach vorn an die rampe
tritt
ganz herzlichen dank
ganz angetan von das jetzt zuerst mal
wahrgenommen diese kleine passage dieser
kleine schlenker mit den lehrjahren des
bestatters irgendwo im europäischen
ausland wo man denkt na ja klar ich
meine die hagen geschichte kennt weiß
dass er anrufe von könig etzel da eben
aufgewachsen ist und dann unter ganz
dramatischen umständen ja dann da da
entflieht
auffällig fand ich auch diese rhythmik
dann in der sprache warum
dieses leichte anziehen an der stelle
und es wird ja es wird ja etwas
schneller
rhythmischer man hat fast den eindruck
aus einer
lesung aus einer aus einem stück prosa
wird eine art andeutung ein hauch eines
liedes
naja es ist unvermeidlich also wir
neigen ja dazu zu glauben dass wenn
jemand
rhythmisiert schreibt oder in versen das
sei sozusagen eine manierierte spielerei
oder zu sagen na ja ich kann auch lampen
oder irgendetwas bei mir ist das nicht
so weil ich automatisch so schreibe das
ist kein plan sondern der stoff selber
die figur der auftritt dieses dieses
dieses dieses geheimnisvollen hagen er
zwingt geradezu die form das
nibelungenlied selber ist natürlich in
versen es gibt wunderbare prosa
übersetzungen und ich hätte es nie in
versen nach gedichtet aber diese
rhythmik ist eigentlich
unausweichlich weil sie der energie des
textes entspricht diese figuren haben
eine unheimliche kraft ganz im sinne des
stummfilms die stehen da und die kann
man nicht in irgendeiner larifari prosa
herunter erzähler muss man schon ein
bisschen ackern und das hat auch
wirklich arbeit gemacht eine andere
struktur die der test ebenfalls vorgibt
das findet sich wieder in den
großkapital bezeichnungen nämlich da
gibt es einmal rein da gibt es donau und
dann gibt es am ende die klage da würde
ich gern gleich zu kommen aber erst mal
zu rhein und donau
es ist natürlich durch die handlung
vorgegeben die eine spielt am rhein er
die andere eher auf der donau und auf
dem weg aber
geht es darüber hinaus also färben diese
beiden flüsse auch hier erzählen ein
oder
geben die daran etwas ja ich wünschte es
wäre so das waren natürlich auch der der
plan in der tat nun ist es so dass mir
durch durch corona das verwehrt blieb
was ich eigentlich bei jedem buch mache
nämlich dass ich den stoffen hinterher
reise also eine donau reise wäre fällig
gewesen den rhein kenne ich ganz gut die
donau weniger und deshalb habe ich mich
ein wenig belesen und es ist ja
natürlich so dass sie rein welt und die
donau welt ganz ganz eklatant
unterschiedliche welten sind und die
zweiteilung ist im original gegeben und
man merkt auch dass die teile nicht in
jeder hinsicht kompatibel sind und die
stimmung an der donau ist eine andere
der ganze donauraum ist anders bevölkert
es tauchen ganz neue personen auf ist es
natürlich dass hunden land und es
spiegelt auch die interessanterweise ja
bis heute
vorhandenen unterschiede oder auch
ängste und projektionen auf diesen osten
den wir heute viel besser kennen und
kennen könnten und zugleich ist die
ganze angst dieser reisenden nibelungen
sie kommen in eine zone die sie nicht
kennen und im gegensatz zu diesem
einfachen klaren
rheinischen ist dieser vielvölker das
ist vielvölker land der donau eine ganz
andere welt ja aber kommt mich auch
hinzu beim rhein
gut wir die wir dass airports kennen die
wir das nibelungenlied kennen wir wir
wissen wohin der hase läuft aber die
nibelungen können eigentlich noch nicht
wissen wie sich das ganze entwickelt
aber in dem moment wo sie auf der donau
sind
gibt es eine prophezeiung die ganz klar
sagt kein einziger von euch wird
zurückkommen außerdem kaplan und tragen
sagt das wollen wir ja mal sehen wirft
den kaplan ins wasser aber wunder der
kann gar nicht schwimmen aber seinen
mantel trägt ihn irgendwie ans ufer und
so und da wissen eigentlich alle und
spätestens dann weiß auch der
unvorbereitete leser das geht nicht gut
aus
also schon von daher ist eine gewisse
schwarze wolke über dem ganzen absolut
und irgend es das ist dann wiederum
folgerichtig im sinne der der
kettenreaktion sie haben mir vor langer
zeit einmal die frage gestellt hätte es
nicht irgendwie anders kommen können
also gebe es die möglichkeit irgendwo in
dem text abzuwiegen und sagen jetzt
wenden wir alles zum guten ich gestehe
ich habe das sogar probiert ich hatte
sogar vor das schlimme zu verhindern
auch neue todesarten auszuprobieren oder
zu denken na ja irgendwie muss man es
zerstört aber sozusagen den charakter
der erzählung damit muss man dann fertig
ich habe jetzt gerade richtig verstanden
das schlimme verhindern indem ich neue
todes orten ausprobieren naja also
nein ich hatte also im grunde genommen
kam mir die nibelungen alle irgendwie
ziemlich
suizidal vor es gibt einen moment von
selbstvernichtung in dem also in dem
hagen sagt ich zerschlage das floß und
damit ist die rückkehr unmöglich gemacht
wir können es auch anders beschreiben
sein es gibt eine art lust am untergang
die natürlich auch ungeheuer
provozierend ist und die man
erzählerisch glaube ich nur bewältigen
kann oder ich nur bewältigen konnte in
dem ich auch ein moment von komödie sie
es gibt auch einen komödiantischen und
komischen zug in der über steigerung da
sind wir wieder beim stummfilm
wenn sie
feststellen wollen wie aus einem großen
köpfe rollen im mittelalter eine
fröhliche tortenschlacht wird rate ich
ihnen dringend das buch zu lesen ganz
herzlichen dank ich bedanke mich
dankeschön
[Applaus]
[Musik]